you can see the heading is absolute
value equations and inequalities now in
theory this is something you already
know how to do but what are we going to
do and you can see it by the very first
word under the heading what we are going
to do is thinking about this visually
now you already know how to approach
many kinds of problems like this totally
with algebra purely with algebra in fact
if you've got given this question here
it would give you completely fine to not
even touch a graph and just to think
about that in pure algebraic terms that
would not be a problem but what happens
is or what starts to happen is that you
start to encounter problems where it
becomes a major hip and your ability to
solve the problem if you cannot think
about it visually okay so we're gonna
start off with ones that you can and
then we're gonna move into areas where
it's like oh there's a clear advantage
here to solving it in a visual way and
not cracking the algebra out at all okay
so where we going to begin with graphing
this guy I'm gonna put on to the axes
we'll use it to solve this equation then
we're also gonna use it to solve a very
closely related
inequality but we'll get to that in a
minute now when you are first thinking
about graphing y equals absolute value
of X minus 2 there's kind of there's
lots of different ways you can think
about it I'm going to show you first
what we do if we think about this guy
inside without the absolute values if I
just asked you to graph y equals X minus
2 no absolute values right we should be
able to be at the point where it's a
straight line I should know what that
looks like right y equals x would be
just gone right through the origin so X
minus 2 which way is it going to go oh
you might normally think of that as oh
it's a it's a bit lower right and it's
gonna go negative 2 and positive 2 okay
but of course this is not the real graph
that we want we want the absolute value
of that and back when we first met
absolute value knew one of the
definitions was well if it's positive
just just take the positive part but if
it's negative what do you do yeah you
like put brackets around that thing if
it's negative and slap a minus sign at
the front in other words visually yeah
we're gonna turn it upside down okay
so you're gonna get this guy like so
okay so this is that bouncy part what's
that shape called where it changes
that's at spot what's I can't it's got
name stuff
it's the cusp right so you like up the
is what sort of gives it that bouncy
kind of quality which is what when I
learn absolute value first I was like oh
these are the bouncy graphs right so you
can do it that way that's fine another
way you can think about it is this think
back to when we were doing hyperbolas
and parabolas and circles this guy here
is a translation of this you know what
this looks like don't you right that's
it's the bouncy graph and it's right
there at the origin that's where the
cusp is so what does this this - - what
does it do - this which way does it
translate yeah it's going to shift
sideways it's going to go two units to
the right like if you had x squared and
then you're like how about X minus 2 or
squared right it moves over yeah so I'm
gonna do the same thing you can see I've
moved over to the right so there's the
absolute value of X but I've shifted
over so let's do this you can see I have
drawn my graph my set of axes comically
large but that's because the biggest
thing is the easier it is to work with
okay so there you go there's y equals
the absolute value of x - 2 I usually
label the equation of my graph right and
I could just say this is the absolute
value of x - 2 but actually gonna go a
step further than that each of these
different branches actually has a
different equation right this guy over
here is just the regular x - 2 but what
did we do to the other side you know how
we were like oh this part bounces up
what do we do to it
yeah it's the minus of that right so you
could either write this as minus X plus
2 or you could write it as 2 minus X
same deal right and you can see off of
that you've got this guy has an
intercept here this guy has an intercept
you said there's the graph ok we've done
the first part graph da da da and now
we're into the second part now there's a
really really excuse me a crucially
important word right in the middle of
this sentence in this problem and we've
mentioned it before but I'm going to
mention again because students often get
it actually in many ways everywhere it
is important but the one that particular
natori attention to is this sky here
okay
okay so what is what is hence me it's a
this a really big deal okay hence means
you did a thing and now on the basis of
what you just did you must use that to
then subsequently do whatever I'm asking
you to do okay if you don't use this
thing to do the second thing you're
actually not answering the second
question right so remember I said to you
or you could if you wanted to solve this
algebraically if that's what you got
given but you've been asked to do this
first and hence so you've got to use the
graph to come up with your solution
right so if I saw a student graph this
right and then they left the graph alone
and then they started doing some algebra
okay basically they've surrendered
they're marked for the second part of
the question right because they haven't
heads solved okay and we might have done
this as a Part A and A Part B you'd
surrender your mark so Part B because
you have ignored the way that the
question is asked you to solve it okay
and we're trying to get at us we're
trying to assess a particular skill so
how do I use this or this rather to
solve this now what this thing is asking
and I'm actually going to ask you to
write this to me it's such an important
sort of idea to have in your head what
this means is when does this graph
intersect with this value okay
when does this graph the equals means
intersect where are these two things
equal to the same thing and it's like
when does this graph intersect this
value okay five is just the number and
where is it going to fit on here well I
can compare y equals the absolute value
X minus two that's a graph already drawn
and I can compare it with the graph y
equals five what kind of line is y
equals five it's get you do it here yeah
okay it's it's horizontal right the way
you know it's horizontal and not
vertical is if the Y value is always
five let's find a place on this graph
where the Y value is five right well
that's two so if I went what is my scale
look like three four five see that point
right there that has a y-value of five
but it's not the only one with a y-value
of five
right here's another spot like here that
the coordinates of that might be 1 comma
5 right mid this around free either
Sibella H so I've got another you know
point and it's coordinates the y-value
is 5 I could keep on going right like
this would be 2/5 3/5 4/5 all the Y
values of 5 so this you can see is going
across it's not a vertical line so let's
go ahead and we can draw us ok so what
you're looking at here is these two
graphs and they do intersect at these
two one two particular points so these
guys here these points of intersection
that's what I'm trying to find when you
read this equation the absolute value of
X minus 2 equals 5 what you're thinking
is when does this guy here the absolute
value of x minus 2 when is it equal 5
you can find those two values then
you're done ok are we looking for the Y
value or the x value like my solution
will it be an X equal something or a
Wike or something it'll be an X equal
something in one of the ways you can do
that is have a look at the question that
they've asked it says solve this guy
right
see how it's this there's no wise in
here I'm using this graph to help me but
it's all about trying to solve for X
right the other thing is all of the Y's
here they're all 5 that's not the
solution you're looking for that's what
you graphed on there ok so you can find
when this thing is equal to 5 and you
can find where this thing is equal to 5
you can actually read this off the graph
if you've done it here's your ruler if
you've got a nice decent scale on here
and you can confirm this algebraically
so over here all right
what does it look like it's going to be
for you it looks like 7 right because
you've got a gradient of 1 on this line
right you're going all the way up to 5
so every time you go up 1 you go across
one up one across one you go do that
five times you're gonna get to 7 right
what about over on this side negative 3
sorry what were using yes so what I've
done right now is I've used the graph
you can see how I said oh there's x
equals negative 3 there's x equals 7
but if I wanted to just for my own sake
now that I have done what the question
is asked
I can check myself I can use the algebra
I can say okay when is X minus two equal
to five well it's not that hard to add
two to both sides you get seven checks
out when is two minus X equal to five
it's takeaway and then I'm gonna
multiply by negative one you're like
cool it makes sense I can VI can check
that for myself but the graph is
actually my means of solving it okay are
you with me so far
yeah yes that's okay
please ask oh you mean this guy that's a
great question
where did this come from because when
you do absolute value right the positive
part just stays what it was before if X
minus two is positive then the absolute
value of X minus two is just X minus two
but if it's negative you see I've got
this like reflection that's why I drew
this part over here see how this is not
the part I want actually want the
negative version of that which is why it
sort of flipped up right so I could have
written it as this it's equal to
negative X minus two but I just didn't
want to write it with two negative signs
so that's why I saw expanded it and I
got that that make sense good question